لم يكتفي الزلزال بتحطيم منازلهم لم يكتفي
بسرقه اسرهم بل سلب من هؤلاء الاطفال حتى
اسمائهم
مجهول كل التفاصيل حاضره اين تم العثور
عليهم كيف ومتع لكن غاب شيء اخر مهم
عنوانهم هوياتهم من هم والى من ينتمون
مسؤول اصحتي في تركيا يحاولون مطابقه
الاطفال المجهولين بالعناوين لكن في
الغالب لا تكون العناوين اكثر من انقاض
وفقا لوزاره الاسره والخدمات الاجتماعيه
في تركيا
سيقيموا هؤلاء الاطفال في دور رعايه او
لدى اسر حاضنه في حال انتهت جميع محاولات
التوصل الى اسرهم او اقاربهم حيث تم
الاعلان عن ارقام للتواصل في حال الرغبه
باحتضان اطفال من ضحايا الزلزال فيما تلقت
الوزاره اكثر من 95 الف طلب لحضانه هؤلاء
الاطفال حتى الان مقابل شروط للتبني
وضعتها سلطات التركيه
نجوا من الزلزال لكنهم وقعوا في اخر قذف
بهم في مصير غامض تم لم شمل بعضهم لكن
كثيرين ما زالوا اطفالا مجهولين هويه
الزلزال
عصام عبد السلام العربيه